[Music]
so we're going to go e5
and we will play other openings here as
well
um bishop c4 this is called the bishop's
opening we're going to develop our
knight
and simultaneously attacked when he goes
d4 okay
so this is an interesting move uh this
essentially opens up the center
immediately
and it does it does attack it does
attack the pawn
so we're going to just take pawn and
we're going to try to get him to develop
his queen early go z5 that's that's the
theoretical move
now this is actually a line and i
actually don't want to move my knight
what you want to look for in such
situations when there's a bishop on c4
in these particular openings are ways to
develop
your pieces and counter-attack your
opponent's pieces so the move here
is actually d5 i'll talk about this
later
the move here is actually d5 he's taken
my knight and i've taken his bishop now
look what happens as a consequence guys
don't worry i will explain this more
slowly later he gives us a check
do we have to move our king do we have
to move our king or can we block the
check
we can't block it with bishop e7 but we
can block it with bishop e6 don't worry
black is
much much better here because
this might look intimidating guys
because of the pawn he can take but
remember
principles don't lie if you abide by
opening principles for the most part and
you develop your pieces and your
opponent gives you a bunch of
intimidating looking checks
he ain't gonna go far again he's trying
to intimidate me
and this is part of the reason that a
lot of beginners slip up they get
intimidated by this stuff
rather than just continuing to develop
okay he finally develops now here's the
thing
would you guys castle short or would you
prepare to castle
long and why
so actually you castle long because if
your castle short
it's very dangerous because he's removed
the g7 pawn which is a vital part of the
pawn cover
and he could start threatening checkmate
with moves such as knight g5 so we're
actually going to castle long
so people get confused okay knight g5 no
threats we're just gonna castle
knock yourself out take my bishop so
he's moving the same two pieces a
million times
and he's going to pay a very very steep
price for this if he doesn't castle
he has to castle otherwise i'm going to
kill him down the c file
okay he's playing well i mean he's
playing i would say like a 7 800
now we're actually going to move this
bishop away and centralize it
and just put it on a better square and
depending on what he does
we're going to develop a plan now in
terms of attacking his king
can anybody propose a plan how are we
going to actually attack
the king what are we going to do and on
what file
what can you notice yes very good guys
man you're good
so because he's removed our pawn from g7
that's not only a bad thing that's also
a good thing we have what's called a
semi-open file which means that
only his pawns are on whoa oh relax
two defenders one attacker
this is a great example of when i would
not trade
because we are so close to essentially
starting an attack against this pawn
and is king and that's going to be a
devastating attack but there is no point
in letting him trade now what do you
guys think we do here
what do you guys think we do here
we need to do something and we need to
move a piece back to its original square
let's keep attacking the spawn yeah
let's move the bishop back to d5
let's start pressuring the spot now we
are ready now to move this bishop away
and then we are going to have a
devastating attack on the pawn
we're also threatening something super
cool
oh okay but he played a5 now here's the
thing guys
he wants to play this annoying move a6
so can we stop that can we stop that can
we just
deal with this right now and then we're
gonna do something beautiful
can we deal with yeah let's play six and
this is called prophylaxis we don't need
to play this move but it's a good idea
to take
care of any annoying threats and we're
actually gonna do something really
beautiful here ah danny stop this
we can actually trap this queen this is
so cool we can trap this queen
we can trap this queen queen h3
almost worked but this is also really
cool
how can we trap the screen yep look at
this
bishop f8 trapping the queen now
when you see a good move look for a
better one is there something even
better than taking the queen
because by playing bishop f8 we've
killed two birds with one stone
we have not only attacked the queen but
we have opened up an attack on the pawn
and here
this is really advanced but we have
checkmate
in two moves who can find me the in two
it's better than a windmill there is
actually an immediate check made in two
moves
this is a very advanced concept but it's
an important one nobody's seen it yet
it's all checks both moves are checks
both moves are checks
queen h3 he can stave off the maid rook
g1
this is a double check don't worry i
will explain everything
i am checking him from two different
sources when you have a double check
only the only way to defend against the
double check is to move the king
there's no other way to defend against
the double check
and queen g4 is checkmate because the
queen is delivering the checkmate
and the bishop is basically preventing
the king from moving back to h1 the rook
is preventing him from moving
to either of these two squares okay that
was an instructive game
let's talk about it so basically
in the opening he played this movie five
okay
now what would be wrong with moving the
knight away well
not only would that violate an opening
principle of not moving the same piece
more than once
but he could actually pick up the pawn
on d4
and simultaneously he attacks the knight
we have to move the knight again
donya i think many people can't keep up
with your commentary um
well i'm sorry to hear that rasheed i'm
really trying my best to explain
everything
as fully as possible and also that's why
i'm going over the game afterward
this is a five minute game so i also
have to play quickly
and i go over the moments very slowly
after the game i'm trying my absolute
best here
to essentially make it interesting for
for everybody
um so this would not be good
now the move d5 is very specifically
it's fine i i appreciate your guys's
support
and i always accept constructive
criticism i appreciate it
and it's totally fine with me now do you
guys see
that i am also attacking the bishop
thank you spectrum for the sub
so he can take my knight and i can take
his special what do i accomplish by
playing d5
well what i accomplish is that i open up
my bishop
and i occupy the center now earlier i
talked about a situation where you have
two pieces hanging
when you have two pieces hanging you
want to think about
moving one of the pieces with check and
then because your opponent has to deal
with the check
you can take the other piece so the move
bishop b5 chair comes with does this win
a piece
does does this win a piece who can who
can answer that question for me
no why not because you can either play
c6
or you can actually play the advanced
move knight after d7
dropping the knight back and
simultaneously defending it
but don't play knight c6 because then he
can already take your knight
okay so he what he should have done is
probably just dropped his bishop back
but then i can already play knight e4
and if you compare this position with
this position
you see that there is one fundamental
difference which is that after queen
takes d4
the knight is no longer under attack and
you can just essentially develop you can
play bishop e6
defending the pawn and then you can play
knight c6 with tempo that's why it's a
bad idea to develop the queen so early
because you can develop pieces by it and
simultaneously attack the queen
okay so he can also play on passat
and i think most of you guys are
familiar with on passant and i'm going
to use this to discuss
the concept of the discovered check
after bishop takes d6
it seems like he can take the pawn on d4
can he take the pawn on d4 yes or no and
why not if no
because the bishop before check this is
called a discovered check you expose the
attack on the queen what if you go c3
what if you go c3 bowler i'll get to
your question in a moment
because if queen takes queen and you
cannot take back because of the pin
okay that is also why undefended pieces
are so important
undefended pieces actually might be the
most important tactical concept
to get your head around as you begin
playing chess and as you progress
through the first stages
especially an undefended queen
especially an undefended queen that is
x-rayed
by the opponent's queen that is the
situation in which you have to be
incredibly cautious
another time that that manifests itself
is in this kind of situation when you're
castled
the king is on a dark square there's
always the possibility
of delivering a check to h2 i've won a
lot of games
precisely in this way i've won a lot of
games precisely in this way
okay so boulder asked the question about
this position what happens if f3 do you
remember guys when i told you that when
you move pawns in front of your king
it's almost always very dangerous
because it opens up diagonals
that the queen could occupy and
essentially create big threats against
the king this is exactly such an example
queen h4 check in fg3 there is a very
typical
very typical tactical idea most of you
have seen this in puzzle rush plenty of
times
which is where you take on g3 now guess
what is the oil that makes this machine
run
undefended pieces again because the rook
is undefended
you can get away with this and just take
the rook and you're up a million things
and your
opponent's position is devastated i hope
that answers your question bowler
so he took i took the queenie two trick
looks
looks scary but it's nothing f takes g7
bishop takes g7 i already have two
pieces developed and i have an extra
pawn and i have a beautiful pawn chain
he has nothing and he continues to dig
himself further into the hole by moving
his queen again
uh i prepare long castle so just to
recap short castle would have been fine
but i didn't want to allow him to create
made threats i mean why allow this when
i have a perfect home for the king
on the queen side castle's long
and i played bishop d5 so already at
this point i started developing a plan
whereby i will essentially put a rook on
g8
i'm going to move this bishop away and
i'm going to try to chase this knight
away from g5 and once i crash through on
g2 the game is going to basically be
over
um just out of curiosity any reason you
chose queen d7 or queen n great
great yes there is there's two reasons
the first is i do not want to allow
this kind of move which pins the queen
to the rook now yes you can play f6
but um this blunts the bishop i want the
bishop to be open
and i just don't want to allow the
possibility of this and the second
reason is that
let's say he does what he did in the
game i i don't want to allow
potentially the rookie one with tempo
neither of these things
are in any way dangerous but it's all
about
taking care of your future self it's all
about playing
so that you minimize the risk of
disaster okay
now you might ask well wait a second
doesn't he have the possibility of that
well no he doesn't because two pieces
are defending the squares 95 is not
possible
so watch out for temple plays that's a
great way of encapsulating that the true
ching
watch out for temple play so when you
develop a piece
watch out for ways that your opponent
can develop
and simultaneously attack your piece
that's called developing with tempo
again that doesn't mean you never try to
allow that sometimes it's not scary at
all sometimes you have to allow
development tempo but
when you have a choice watch out for
that okay
so he plays a4 making a motion to attack
us on the queen side but he doesn't have
any pieces there so it's not scary
rook dg8 knight takes f7 was just
terrible i mean he does our bidding for
us and he blunders the knight
we just come back to d5 to keep
pressuring the pun now had he played
queen a4
i would have had a beautiful move in
this position
and in order to find this move in order
to find this move
how do i think about this the first
question i ask myself
what would have happened let's say this
pod were gone if this one were gone the
king would be trapped
which means any check with them with my
dark squared bishop
would be made next question can we get
rid of this pawn
first move that comes to mind is bishop
takes you two this is a very typical
mistake
people follow the logic so far then they
say bishop takes you two but remember
by sacrificing the bishop and of course
black is still winning
you have relinquished your control over
the h1 square so remember
that when you're trying to remove a
piece or a pawn make sure that you're
not sacrificing the piece that is
responsible
for the mating mechanism the correct
move here is queen h3 sacrificing the
queen
nothing extraordinary but very nice g
takes h3 is essentially forced
now we just move the bishop away white
does have bishop g5 but rook takes g5 is
checkmate
okay so this is not a mythical move
hopefully i've shown you the kind of
logic that can be used
to unearth a move like this there's far
more advanced
advanced instances of this type of
tactic this is essentially removing the
defender or decoy
there's a lot of names for this that's
the idea now by playing queen c5
why has he prevented queen h3 why has he
prevented this move or has he prevented
it
i know that we trapped his queen but
could we have also done this
this leads me to something that i call
the queen syndrome
yes nanuka very good nanuka says queen
takes d5
and we don't take the queen we take the
bishop instead the queen syndrome
is refers to two things and one of them
is when people see a queen hanging
they assume that the queen must be
captured
a boat says gambit can be declined guys
remember that
you don't have to take anything and so
people forget
that you can take something other than
the queen or you can just ignore a queen
sacrifice that's a very powerful device
that we will flesh out a lot more when
we talk about defending
i'm going to write this down because i
want to keep track of what i've talked
about
okay so we played bishop f8 rook takes
you too now
how do you find rook she won check again
the rook is actually an obstruction okay
i realized that remember guys when we
asked ourselves the question what
happens if the g2 pawn were gone
it's basically the same thing the jeep
coupon is now done
the jupiter 21 is now gone so all we
need to do
is simply get the king back to the g
file and then we can check him down the
g file and it's going to be checkmate
the trueching asks can you not just back
up the rook to g4 well not quite because
i can play f3
and this comes back to something i said
earlier which is that you
can block a check remember that when
you're considering a check you look not
only for king retreats
there's no king retreat to hide
checkmate but you can also block a check
with pieces and you need to check for
that get it
when you are considering moves now
last thing would this also result in
checkmate
well not really because now the f2 pawn
was an integral part of the king being
locked in
so if we do the same thing he can now
take the rule now what could we do here
we could go back to g2 and then we could
go back to g3 and because there is no
longer a pawn on f2
he has to block with a rook and this is
just checkmate so we could do that this
is called a windmill
this particular device we can also take
all of his pieces where you essentially
check him
then move away with a discover check
then move back with a check
is called a windmill there are many
famous examples of a windmill it's one
of my favorite tactical devices
and we will talk a lot more about that
later but cash flow reel with 10 bucks
any thoughts on king safety
versus keeping up quick beast
development in the attack i find i miss
prioritize this
sometime very good question so cash flow
reel is asking
um how do we know whether to develop a
piece or to castle
um i don't have and thank you so much
for the 10 bucks
i don't have a shorthand answer for you
i would say that usually
castling here's the thing castling is a
lot more committal
than development because in virtually
any position you know that development
is a good idea but castling could be
very dangerous if it later turns out
that the side on which you castle gets
opened up
or gets gets um exposed in some way
so here's what i'll say as a beginner if
your rating is let's say below 700
your priority should be to castle as
early as possible
because it's a lot more important to
build good habits than to find
exceptions to the rule
you need to learn how to treat your king
well and most of the time nothing bad is
going to happen if you castle a little
bit too early
as a relatively advanced player what you
need to start practicing is the concept
of flexibility there are some positions
where you want to leave your king in the
center for two reasons sometimes the
king is safer in the center
than it is on one side of the board that
happens and another reason is sometimes
you don't know whether you want to
cancel long or short
and so you delay that decision but you
don't procrastinate too long but you
delay it
until things have clarified until your
opponent has indicated
on which side of the board he would
rather attack and then you can make an
informed decision about where you want
to castle
let's see if i can apply that here so
here would be a great example of that
right
i don't want a castle yet because i know
that this side of the board is kind of
weak
now you might be like so you wouldn't
castle short but that doesn't answer my
question well maybe i would have
if he would have swung his queen to the
other side of the board
i might very well have said okay now he
he's not going to attack on the king's
side
now i might castle um
yeah sometimes the king is safer in the
middle uh if you're an advanced player
and you want more information about this
i highly recommend the book the art of
attack in chess
it's an old old book written by an iem i
think first published in the 1920s but
there's modern versions
and there is actually a chapter on the
king remaining in the center
um and when you should do that so if you
want to read more about that
highly recommended art of attack and
chess by vladimir
you can just search it on google get it
on amazon get it on your kindle
if you're serious about learning how to
attack one of the best books ever
written
on attacking chess highly recommend it
for players i would say over 12 1300
plenty of stuff on the tax
[Music]